okay let's play green master alexander
he's very very strong
i lost to alexeyenko now i'm going to
lose to oleg cinco
and you know all the the whole family
basically the whole family is going to
have a go with me guys
who else is there alexandra alexandro
all of them all of them ruski's
no he's from ukraine it's just a
different country
knight f3 okay i'm gonna play my main
stuff knight c6
okay i'm gonna play theory
i'm gonna play my main prep
okay a6
93 yeah it's 93 first p5 95 what
okay very solid oh you have increments
i'm not going to be able to oh we should
go six okay
okay that's how i gonna do it
that's how i'm gonna play it i'll go f5
bishop d3 i think i go bishop to e6
interesting i think i'm
c3 yeah oh boy
oh boy
yeah that's there that is most certainly
there okay let me think a bit
um
yeah i think i can castle here i think
he takes i go shoot d5 of 6 e4
i have 0 key a's yeah i think that's the
line
i think that's the line
bishop it's all 95 i think it's a
possible move
i think that's all right my my pawn on
g7 is the pawn
seven you know we don't care about it
it's a white pawn
uh we don't care about it it's there
bring the queen out to f6
to be around equal but
a lot of play left here
and you should still stay loyal to the
nitrophyte definitely
this stuff is uh costing me a lot of
time
a lot of time i should stick to the good
stuff like the night of
knight c4 b3 queen c3
let's try let's try let's try bt knight
d2 is also oh the knight comes to e3
it's tricky maybe i should have gone bc
should have gone busy probably probably
should have gone
can i play b no can i play a rookie yeah
knight e3 okay this is
what is that oh this is an interesting
move
what is going on rookie five knight g4
is a very pretty tactic
i self queen g5 no no i shouldn't do
this
knight takes e3 would be really sad
what am i supposed to do in such a
position
i don't know knight 63 is bad
yeah i should stick to my kids just
stick to neighborhood don't do this kind
of
nonsense unprovoked
i should have gone bc i think i don't
know maybe i should have done something
else
this is somehow slightly dodgy not the
good kind of doji
like mr doji the bad kind of dodgy
lots of weaknesses you know this d5
square g-force [ __ ]
little weaknesses then we had such stuff
in either
little weak squares
i should play the dragon i mean now that
i myself
what's the self-proclaimed self-acclaim
self-claimed
self-exclaimed self-proclaimed
expert on the dragon
is there ever a good kind of doji it's
official guys magnus blank dodge
invitational
goddamn
i don't didn't think so but uh
that would be cool that'll be cool i
didn't think magnus was playing
invitational
not the dodgy one at least but that
would be really cool actually why
wouldn't he he plays all kinds of dodgy
stuff
that's far more dodgy than the dodge
invitational he plays some kind of
arenas that don't even
that people i mean literally nobody
cares about these arenas still plays
them
into six
why don't you play doji arena yeah i'm
uh basto
i'm total basto
but i'm going to fight
i can tell you that much my fighting
plan is simple
boys i'm gonna go h4 i like at least i
like that i got h5h4 in
i like that because at least that's some
sort of
okay don't do so don't do this kind of
things it's annoying
h4 okay no i shouldn't go oh god oh god
what are we going to do
with b5 king 7 rookie 4 would be 5.
rookie 4 rookie 4. is it looking for
even a real threat
you're about to find out aren't we yeah
it's a threat i think
ruby 528 can you sound
yeah could be worse could be worse
could be better it could be same
how do you avoid showing a special
preparation like this
are you saying that you don't watch mr
dodge's stream shame on you
yeah guys mr doji apparently a big
streamer you know
i should be okay here more or less now i
should be okay
i mean what's the big deal
hello say hello to my little friend
tricks guys tricks tricks
and as it goes guys the tricks
come synchronized with the time trouble
classic
classic
classic there's a trick there is a time
there is a victory
so lucky so lucky
so lucky